Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Connors. Just answering some of your questions.
Here's a great question that came in. My body has been fighting the tumors with natural support.
Tumors have been unofficially shrinking by examine and unofficially and my unofficial imaging.
And I'm convinced that the tumors are also getting closer to the surface of my skin,
and away from my body cavity, this person has a breast cancer.
Sometimes the skin is in the areas hot and red and sometimes slightly bluish-tinned.
These seem to coincide with good responses.
I understand this moving to the skin is a good thing.
However, my oncologist is fearful of this telling me that it gets in my skin and can spread all over my body.
Please help me understand why I should not be afraid of the tumor.
Moving towards the skin and breaking through the skin.
So first of all, just so we clarify things, all statistics show that when a tumor, especially a breast cancer,
is moving towards the skin, that's a good thing.
It's when it moves towards the chest wall that would be considered a bad thing.
So when it moves towards the chest wall, it adheres to the chest wall.
It has the chance of a testicizing into the chest cavity, into the lung, into the liver.
When it's a moving towards the surface, that's always a good thing.
So why your oncologist would say that he's fearful of it moving towards the surface is beyond me,
because there's no evidence of that.
They probably give you a fear, scare if it was no matter which way it was moving.
So that's just kind of the way things roll in those offices.
So when there's a red response, that's typically a response of inflammation, that's a good thing.
So you say, oh, inflammation is bad, but no, when you're firing in immune response to something, that's inflammatory.
So there's acute inflammatory responses of an immune response to a cancer is a good thing.
And it could actually cause a subtle enlargement of the tumor.
It could make it look larger, because there's some inflammatory response around that cancer.
So don't be fooled about that.
So it's very good that it appears by palpation that is shrinking,
that it appears by maybe thermography and ultrasonic things that it's shrinking.
Those are very good things.
And it's a very good thing that it's moving towards the skin.
But I do want to make a comment in this last part.
Please help me understand why I should not be afraid of the tumor breaking the skin.
Well, in my mind, you shouldn't be afraid of the tumor breaking through the skin
because the tumor is basically trying to come out.
When it does break through the skin, now we have the ability to use surface killers,
like salves, black salve, blood root, things like that,
that can be beneficial to help kill the cancer.
When it's deeper there, you can't use topicals to help kill the cancer
because we can't get in it.
However, that being said, I realize not everybody has the intestinal fortitude
to have their skin break open and the cancer start coming out
and have the desire to deal with it maybe weeping, it might be bleeding,
and have the fear of putting on a black salve.
Currently, we have another women that are doing that with great success.
However, I do realize too that not every woman with breast cancer is willing to walk that walk.
And that's okay, too. It doesn't mean it doesn't mean it's bad.
Sometimes, if that's the case, then maybe doing some people are more comfortable
with doing a mastectomy or doing some chemotherapy along with the actual things.
That's okay too. Everybody's got to walk that walk and make that judgment.
But I would say there can be benefit to it breaking through the skin.
You just have to be ready to go through the consequences of that too.
It's going to definitely make giant mishapes of your breast.
There's going to be wounds that are going to heal.
There's positives and negatives of that too, so we just need to understand all the aspects of that.
Additionally, if my body is doing well without chemotherapy,
will adding chemotherapy actually help my body's work that has already been doing?
Or will it destroy all that good things that my body is doing?
So will adding chemotherapy add to my body killing the cancer?
Or will it kind of set me back? That's a great question.
And nobody could really answer that question perfectly because there isn't a perfect answer.
What your body will do may be very different than somebody else's body will do.
Now, I could make the argument both ways.
I could make the argument, boy, you're doing such a great job.
Your body's killing this cancer. It's shrinking.
You're having all these great results.
Just stay the course. Keep doing this.
And that might be right for 50% of the people.
But also, I could make the argument, your body's doing great.
It's killing the cancer.
Let's now hit it with some harder things too, like chemotherapy.
And we're going to be just going to the right direction and this is going to knock it down.
And that might be perfect for 50% of the people.
So you have to feel comfortable, which way God is leading you.
I think you could make the argument either way.
You don't know how you're about maybe if you do chemotherapy.
It's going to knock you for a loop.
And it's going to maybe knock it down.
But then it's going to grow back faster.
We just don't have those answers. Nobody has those answers.
I can't tell you that answer.
Don't listen to anybody that can give you these dogmatic answers or these instances
because there isn't one.
Everybody is different.
Second part of this question.
I've had one infusion and a question whether it's right for me,
given how well my body has been working on the cancer without it.
That's a great comment there because you have to find out if it's right for you.
And the only way you know that is you have to have peace in your heart about that.
And I tell people over and over again, this is how I deal with it.
I believe that God, he's promised to put his desires in my heart
if I seek after him with my whole heart.
So that is my work in life.
Is to seek after him and to be begging him to give me a desire to do that.
A desire for his word and a desire for that relationship with him.
That I could know, that I know, that I know what his will is for me.
And that should be my main concern.
That whether I should do keyboard or not, but Lord, I need to have a relationship with you
close enough that I feel comfortable that I know which way you're leading me.
And then I can trust wholeheartedly in you, regardless of what that is.
If I believe God's leading me to do keyboard, well, then I want you to have the best attitude going in there
and doing keyboard because God has sent me here to do keyboard.
And he's going to have this work for me just the way he wants it to work for me.
Maybe not the way I want it to work, but the way he wants it to work for me
and therefore he's going to get all the glory.
If he, if my desire is to seek after him and I'm seeking after him
and I'm asking for him for a passion, a greater passion for him,
greater knowledge for him and greater wisdom so that I can walk in that wisdom
and be obedient to that wisdom, he will give that to me if that's what my heart is.
And I'm going to have peace about my decision.
And if my decision is to, you know, I still feel right about this.
He will, I'm going to cancel it.
There's nothing wrong with doing that.
It doesn't mean just because you agree to he will therapy
that you have to do it every three weeks.
You can skip a week. You can skip a session.
You can stop after one. You can stop after two.
You can postpone it for six months.
If you don't have an oncologist that will work with you that way,
then find a different oncologist.
You have to be obedient to Christ.
Before you will be obedient to anybody else, okay?
How do I know if I be obedient to Christ?
I don't know. I want to be obedient to God.
Well, then you need to seek after him first.
Seek him first and all else will be given to you.
So seek him and tell you no.
And then don't do anything. You'll tell you no.
Seek him and ask him for those desires that he's promised you.
I love this verse.
So 28, 28, fear the Lord.
That is wisdom.
That's what wisdom is.
Fear the Lord.
Desire after him.
Seek after him.
Just fear.
Be it away from him.
Not knowing him.
And then depart from evil.
Then follow him.
That is understanding.
Listen to him. Be obedient to him.
Don't act out of fear.
Don't act out of being bullied.
You don't act out of anything other than what God has placed
in your heart and following that.
Listen to that.
That's my recommendation.
I hope that helps.